[Musique]
non c'est une alerte rouge à l'orangé
pour mes chaussons moi c'est zoé djs et
leur arrêt de bourg blanc et lui c'est
paul bonjour des jo bonjour ça nos deux
familles n'en former plus qu'une allée
de vous la compagnie
lève toi ou je poste cette photo sur ton
instagram dans 3 août au matin si tu me
touches pas morts on jouera toi aussi
luna que j'adore juste un peu trop
d'accessoires gère couple comprend on
sèche linge encore cassé a fait pour les
sanctions rapidement chute à linge à
léon ce crime c'est là mais non c'est
nous regarde tous comme si comme si on
venait d'une autre planète merci
beaucoup merci qu'il place
étaient plus nombreux que d'habitude
c'est moi je les ai pas tous reconnu
nous sommes les baker
les enfants sans ne nous arrête tu as
dix enfants je suis peut-être bizarre
mais moi ça me plaît mais moi aussi une
preuve qu'il avance et moi aussi
qu'est ce qu'on se marre
la danse de titres comme un petit
résister à des enfants aussi à doha pour
plus vous faites n'importe quoi il faut
croiser les bras comme ça et paf on
lance vous êtes la honte de la famille
dans votre chambre en ayez pitié de moi
seigneur pour montrer aux enfants qu'on
est une équipe soudée et inviter les
jackson nine si vous cherchez disneyland
vous avez fait un énorme détour
[Musique]
unsa nie ces faits pour s'entraider ok
c'est vrai tout le monde qu'un
jeu
merci d'être aussi accessible est normal
tant physique ordinaire encore standard
à quoi vous jouez 11 de vrac ce terminal
j'adore la vitesse
o les pentes
je veux bien
c'est pas du tout ce que vous croyez que
rien à voir avec fast and furious et des
paris d'argent avec de noël tout à coup
je réalise qu'on n'est pas plus mal en
goût